a square is a rectangle because
rectangle just means a four-sided shape
with all right angles rect angles if the
sides of a rectangle are not all the
same length it's an oblong rectangle but
if they are all the same length it's a
square a rhombus is any four-sided shape
whose sides are all the same length so a
square is a kind of rhombus a kite is a
four-sided shape that is symmetric along
a diagonal so a square is a kind of kite
as well a parallelogram is a four-sided
shape with opposite sides that are
parallel meaning a square is a kind of
parallelogram but what if only one pair
of opposite sides are parallel well
that's a trapezoid but many
mathematicians say that trapezoid just
means at least one pair of opposite
sides are parallel in which case squares
are trapezoids as well as being
parallelograms kites rhombuses and
rectangles it may not be hip to be
square but to be square is to be many
things